♪ ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THE NEWS STACKS UP AND WE
FINALLY GET ANSWERS.
WE HAVE SOME TONIGHT.
AFTER YEAR OF RESEARCH AND
INTERVIEWS THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAS
FINALLY CONCLUDED ITS
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS
RUSSIAN MEDDLING DURING THE
2016 ELECTION THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN HEARING SO MUCH ABOUT.
THE FINAL REPORT IS OUT.
IT'S MORE THAN 200 PAGES
LONG.
HERE'S THE HEADLINE.
INVESTIGATORS FOUND NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION OR
COORDINATION OF ANY KIND
BETWEEN THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT AND THE DONALD
TRUMP FOR PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGN.
NONE.
SO THAT'S BAD NEWS FOR THE
OTHER CABLE CHANNELS.
THEY PROBABLY OUGHT TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE ENTIRE
LAST YEAR OF THEIR
PROGRAMMING BUT OBVIOUSLY
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
BUT TO THE REST OF US, THERE
IS REALLY NO SURPRISE HERE
BECAUSE THERE WAS NEVER ANY
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
IT WAS ALWAYS A FANTASY.
BY THE WAY, THE REPORT DOES
NOT OFFER ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
DIRECTED THE HACKING OF THE
DNC SERVERS OR JOHN
PODESTA'S G MAIL ACCOUNT
EITHER.
TO THIS DAY, THOUGH NO ONE
EVER SAYS IT, NO ONE HAS
EVER CAME UP WITH ANY PROOF
THAT HAPPENED DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ALL
REQUIRED TO BELIEVE THAT
HAPPENED OR ELSE WE ARE
RUSSIAN AGENTS OURSELVES BUT
WHATEVER.
THERE IS NOT A LOT NEW ABOUT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN THIS
REPORT.
THERE IS QUITE A BIT ABOUT
HOW WASHINGTON ACTUALLY
WORKS.
CONSIDER FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE JIM
CLAPPER.
FOR YEARS, CLAPPER WAS ONE
OF THE MOST POWERFUL
INTELLIGENCE CHIEFS IN THE
WORLD.
NOW IS HE A CABLE NEWS
SHOUTER AND POLITICAL
ACTIVIST.
HE IS ALSO A PROLIFIC LIAR.
ACCORDING TO TODAY'S REPORTS
IN SWORN TESTIMONY TO
CONGRESS, UNDER OATH.
CLAPPER CLAIMED THAT HE
NEVER DISCUSSED THE STEELE
DOSSIER WITH ANYONE IN THE
PRESS.
THAT'S UNTRUE.
THE REPORT REVEALED THAT
CLAPPER WHISPERED TO CNN
ABOUT THE STEELE DOSSIER AND
MONTHS LATER, OF COURSE, THE
NETWORK HIRED HIM AS A
CONTRIBUTOR.
HE STILL IS ONE.
YESTERDAY JIM COMEY TOLD OUR
FRIEND BRET BAIER THAT
CLAPPER ENCOURAGED HIM TO
DISCUSS THE DOSSIER WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT BRIEFS WAS LATER USED
BY CNN AND OTHER MEDIA
OUTLETS TO JUSTIFY REPORTING
ON THES TO YEA.
AND SO ON IN THE CIRCULAR
FASHION WE HAVE BEEN
WATCHING FOR THE LAST YEAR.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE WHOLE
THING WAS A SETUP FROM THE
BEGINNING.
NO ONE EVER BELIEVED THE
DOES QUAY WAS TRUE OR CARED
IF IT WAS TRUE.
IT WAS ALWAYS JUST A TOOL
DESIGNED TO HAMSTRING THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT
PERMANENT WASHINGTON OPPOSED
FROM DAY ONE.
TRUMP WAS ON TO THIS
ACTUALLY FROM THE BEGINNING.
HE COULDN'T REALLY EXPLAIN
IT, BUT HE COULD SMELL IT,
WHICH IS HIS ONE GREAT
TALENT AND HE WAS RIGHT.
OF COURSE, HE WAS ATTACKED
MERCILESSLY FOR SUGGESTING
THE SO-CALLED INTEL
COMMUNITY MIGHT NOT BE ON
THE LEVEL.
HOW DARE HE DO THAT HE
YELPED ON CNN.
THEY ARE PUBLIC SERVANTS
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
KEEPING YOU SAFE BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
ACTUALLY SOME OF THEM ARE
PEOPLE.
SOME ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
SOME ROTTEN AND UNETHICAL.
SOME WOULD USE LEAKS,
DECEPTION AND INTEND DOUGH
TO REVERSE RESULTS OF AN
ELECTION.
MOST PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
THIS THAT'S WHY THE PHRASE
DEEP STATE IS SUDDENLY PART
OF THE PUBLIC CONVERSATION.
JOHN BRENNAN IS PART OF THE
REASON BY THE WAY.
BRENNAN IS THE FORMER HEAD
OF THE CIA AND LIKE JIRMT
CLAMMER IS ENTHUSIASTIC
LIAR.
LIKE CLAPPER HE HAS BEGUN
SECOND CAREER AS LEGAL
ANALYST.
BRENNAN DENOUNCED THE ENTIRE
THING AS MEANINGLESS.
HE THEN SAID THIS ON TWITTER
DIRECTLY TO THE PRESIDENT,
QUOTE THE:  THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S FINDINGS WILL BE
COMPREHENSIVE AND
AUTHORITATIVE, STAY TUNED,
MR. TRUMP.
HE AUDITED
HE AUDIT AN ELLIPSIS TO MAKE
IT EXTRA OMINOUS, WHICH IT
WAS.
OKAY.
SO THE LONG-TIME CHIEF OF A
SHADOWY INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
IS WARNING THE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY
THAT SOMETHING BAD IS ABOUT
TO HAPPEN TO HIM.
APPARENTLY BECAUSE JOHN
BRENNAN HAS INSIDE KNOWLEDGE
THE REST OF US DON'T.
BUT DON'T LET THAT BOTHER
YOU.
DON'T GET PARANOID OR
ANYTHING.
DON'T BUY ANY OF THOSE NUTTY
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT
THE DEEP STATE.
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
JUST BE SURE TO OBEY OUT
PERMANENT GOVERNMENT IN
WASHINGTON OR ELSE GOONS
LIKE JOHN BRENNAN WILL CRUSH
YOU.
TERRY TURCHIE IS FORMER
DEPUTY ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNTER TERRORISM.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY SENIOR
EDITOR AT THE FEDERALIST.
THEY JOIN US TONIGHT.
MOLLIE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
WHAT'S THE TAKE AWAY.
>> THEY FOUND AFTER A YEAR
OF RIGOROUS INVESTIGATION
THERE IS NO ACTUAL EVIDENCE
OF TREASONOUS COLLUSION
BETWEEN TRUMP AND RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S PROBABLY THOUGHT VERY
SURPRISING.
WHAT THEY DID SHOW WAS THAT
THERE IS QUITE A LOT OF
COLLUSION AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO COOK
UP AND PROPAGATE A NARRATIVE
OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
WE HAD ALREADY LEARNED FROM
THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
FISA ABUSE AT DOJ WHERE THEY
USED A RESEARCH DOCUMENT
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR SECRETLY
BY HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE TO SECURE A
WIRETAP ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AFFILIATE.
AND THEN YOU PICKED UP ON
THIS OTHER THING THAT'S
INTERESTING.
JAMES CLAPPER GAVE
CONTRADICTORY TESTIMONY
UNDER OATH ABOUT WHAT HE WAS
LEAKING TO CNN.
AND THAT IS INTERESTING.
THE WHOLE THING THAT GOT
EVERYTHING GOING WAS THIS
BRIEFING OF PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP, SUPPOSEDLY ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
WE LATER LEARNED IT WAS ONLY
ABOUT ONE SALACIOUS PART OF
THE DOSSIER.
>> THIS WAS HIGHLY PLACED.
THIS WAS WELL-SOURCED.
OBVIOUSLY.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WENT TO
CLAPPER OR SOMEONE CLOSE TO
HIM AND LEARNING THAT THIS
WAS ALL DONE, THAT COMEY WAS
ASKED TO BRIEF
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP ON
THIS DOSSIER AND THAT THIS
WAS DONE BECAUSE CNN NEEDED
A NEWS HOOK IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY WRITING ABOUT A
DOSSIER.
THAT IS A VERY INTERESTING
DETAIL TO LEARN AND SHOULD
PUT A LOT OF THE COVERAGE
THAT WE HAVE SEEN FOR THE
LAST 15 MONTHS IN AN
ENTIRELY NEW LIGHT.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, TERRY,
YOU SPENT A LOT OF YOUR LIFE
WORKING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY THAT HAS INTELLIGENCE
COMPONENTS TO IT THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE AGENCY,
I'M SURE IS IMPORTANT TO
YOU.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME AS AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
NONE OF THIS SEEMS TO HELP.
I MEAN, IF THERE IS NO
COLLUSION AT THE BOTTOM OF
ALL OF THIS, THEN ALL OF
THIS IS STARTING TO LOOK
VERY POLITICAL AND THAT'S
BAD FOR THE WAY CITIZENS
FEEL ABOUT THEIR GOVERNMENT.
ISN'T IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS, THE REAL
DANGEROUS PART OF THIS AND
THE PART THAT SHOULD SCARE
EVERY ONE OF US, YOU JUST
NAMED THEM.
THE HEADS OF THE MAJOR
INTELLIGENCE INVESTIGATIVE
AGENCY OF THE UNITED STATES,
THE CIA AND THE FBI AND THE
NSA, AWFUL THESE PEOPLE AT
THE TOP APPEAR TO HAVE HAD
JUST ONE GOAL IN MIND.
AND THAT WAS TO BE
ANTI-TRUMP AND TO MAKE
TROUBLE FOR HIM AFTER HE
BECAME THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING THAT ALL OF THIS
IDEA OF UNMASKING, FOR
EXAMPLE, DIDN'T REALLY START
UP UNTIL AFTER HE BECAME
ELECTED.
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY
THOUGHT AND I THINK MOLLIE
AND YOU AND I WOULD NOT BE
SITTING HERE TODAY AND
TALKING HAD HILLARY CLINTON